So back in my editor, I'm just going to go to the content folder.
I'm going to right click in the empty space here in the lighter gray space.
I'm just going to create a new folder.
I'm going to call this materials.
It just keeps things nice and organized and in its own space.
And then I'm going to hit enter with it selected.
And then that just goes to the materials folder.
You can of course just go through the content folder file structure and select materials.
I'm going to now right click and I'm going to select material.
Now thinking about naming conventions before, I'm going to say m underscore color material
and I'm going to spell color the British way.
I'm probably not going to call it material actually because the prefix at the start denotes
that it's material.
So I'm just going to call it m underscore color.
I'm going to hit enter and then enter again and that will load up the material editor.
Now I'm just going to pin this at the top of the window here.
And if I go back to the editor, if that didn't open for you, you can just double click it
as well.
That also will open it.
I'm just going to shut this plugins by middle mouse button in on the wheel and that shuts
any windows there.
You can also just hit there close.
You may not even have that plugins open.
So the first thing I want to do is using our shortcuts before that we showed on the slides,
I'm going to hold the number three on my keyboard and left mouse click and that will create
a vector three.
And I'm just going to drag into the base color and then I'm going to hold down wall one,
the number one on the keyboard, sorry, and left click and put that into metallic.
I'm going to hold down one again, left click and go into roughness.
So we should have something that looks like this.
Now first thing I want to do is change this color.
So I'm going to select the vector three node.
I'm going to click on the color constants here.
I'm just going to pick a color, whatever you prefer and just hit OK.
And that gives us some kind of color value here.
Now, depending on how we want this material to look, we can set some default values.
I'll set one on the metallic just to give it a metallic look for now.
We'll be editing this, but that gives it a nice metallic look.
Just hit one.
Now, if I save this material, that material is good to apply to an actor in any of the
maps that we've got.
However, we want a more streamlined way of working with material instances.
So first thing I'll do here is I will right click.
I'm going to convert to a parameter.
I'm just going to call this color.
And again, spell color, however you would normally spell color.
I'll spell it the British way.
And I'm going to hit save.
And that's going to save the material.
And then I'm going to actually close the material.
Now, what I want to do now is selecting the material, I'm going to right click and create
a material instance.
I'm going to call this MI underscore color.
And I'm going to call this underscore 01 as well.
So I'm going to be creating multiple instances of these.
Now, I'm going to hit enter again to open this.
I'm going to pin my window.
Now, if you notice, if I double click this, now it's a condensed version of that material
that we saw.
I'm just holding down right click to zoom in and out.
You can also change how the material looks in the preview there if you so wish.
But you'll see now we have this color parameter, which we can tick and actually change the
color directly.
So again, as we were talking about, this is a condensed version of the nodes.
This is a really nice, powerful way to edit the material instance.
Now, what we can also do, you'll see color is here, but none of the other properties
are.
What we can do is we can go back into our content library and we can double click the
color and we can actually right click on these as well to convert them to parameter.
So I'll right click there and type metallic.
I'm going to right click on this, convert to a parameter and call it roughness.
And I'm going to save and then I will close the material.
And now we can see we've got a metallic and roughness value.
So if I want to select these and say, well, I actually want metallic to be zero now, or
I want roughness to be, you know, point four, for example, we can actually do this and start
creating materials that we want.
Now, if I save and close, I can actually duplicate this and it'll call it 02.
I can duplicate it again and call it 03.
And now we have really powerful functionality going on.
We can have metallic surfaces with more roughness.
Maybe I want to change the color here.
And you can just start playing around and dialing in all the different properties that
you want.
Again, I'm just paying windows and loading the instances.
And you can see instead of creating this graph every time and I'll leave metallic at zero
there, roughness one.
And you'll see that very quickly we now have three different materials based on this parent
material, which have a powerful functionality of customization.
They're much lighter weight.
Using these material instances is just much lighter weight than using this parent color.
So hopefully that gives you a good idea about how to use parent materials and material instances.
And the main thing you've taken away here is that when you have these materials, you
right click convert to a parameter.
It says convert back to a constant because it's already a parameter.
But if you create a node and you right click to a parameter, you can actually convert that
to a parameter and make it editable within that material instance.